the looming threat of tropical storm
anri the system is gaining strength and
is expected to reach hurricane status
today bringing with it potentially
damaging winds torrential rain and
widespread coastal flooding amri's track
targets new york's long island and
southern new england tomorrow hurricane
watches and warnings are up in those
areas in massachusetts residents on cape
cod are leaving nothing to chance some
people were hauling their boats out of
the water power crews are also on ready
for expected outages henry could become
the first hurricane to hit new england
since hurricane bob came ashore 30 years
ago this week the category 2 storm
killed 17 people and caused more than a
billion dollars in damage for more on
henry's path let's go to meteorologist
jeff varadelli jeff what's latest good
morning michelle we should let you know
that we're only about 30 hours away from
landfall could be eastern long island it
could even be southeast new england but
the good news last night lots of wind
shear take a look at this frontal system
right here kind of sheering the system
out it's kind of elongated so it's still
a tropical storm not yet a hurricane we
hope it stays that way but it has a
chance to strengthen over the next 24
hours winds are still 70 miles an hour
so here's a look at the watches and
warnings you can see hurricane warnings
out for the east end of long island into
connecticut and we also have storm surge
warnings for a lot of the coastline
could be three to five feet of storm
surge so we have to watch this upper
level low very closely because a
corridor is going to open up in between
high and a low and water temperature is
way above normal two to five degrees
above normal so it could very well
strengthen in this window but watch that
upper level though capture the
circulation of anri kind of pulling it
and tugging it northwest and then
slowing it down big inland flood threat
as we head into sunday night and into
monday as well it's going to take its
time across new england
this is a look at the future radar and
the official forecast track from the
national hurricane center notice they do
take it up to hurricane status off new
jersey with winds of 80 miles an hour
and then landfall happens late morning
early afternoon anywhere in this cone so
anywhere from queens in new york
all the way out east towards rhode
island could be in the core of this
system as it moves to the northwest and
as it does so it has a lot of impacts
it's going to cause and one of those
strong gusty winds watch these winds as
we head into the morning
now into the afternoon gusts over 80
miles an hour across eastern long island
and then that begins to weaken the wind
threat weakens a little bit but then we
worry about the rain threat this could
be a big inland flood threat all the way
up through connecticut let's say the
hudson valley and northward from there
some places will see as much as four to
eight inches of rain the bottom line
here is today is the day to take last
minute preparations tomorrow things
really go downhill very quickly
especially in long island and across
southeast new england
all right jeff thank you